[Music]
he's jim miller the author of ESPN book
saturday night live book as well and
kind enough to join us here in the man
cave good to see you thanks for making
the visit here thanks alright
why cutbacks at ESPN give me fact from
fiction you know the numbers that we're
looking at and it says talent they're
gonna be cutting talent at ESPN why
right so let's be clear talent can also
mean not only people who are on camera
all the time but for instance writers
who you know cuz ESPN puts a lot of
their writers on television as well ok
so you got to include them as well but
it's it's basically just talent why
because the times have caught up with
them in part because of these crazy
deals i mean look the last NBA deal that
was 480 480 million dollars a year and
now i think they're paying 1.4 billion i
mean just think about that i like
there's a weird kind of schizophrenia to
it right which is we're all talking
about how ratings are kind of going down
and there's a lot of pressure on these
networks yet at the same time these
deals get bigger and bigger and bigger
i mean i thought with the big 10 deal
for instance I thought well big 10 is
not gonna be able to pull off you know
what what they thought they were gonna
pull off several years ago because of
all the changes all sudden like Fox and
ESPN what like real money on the table
I'm in the NBA deals I'm not enough to
make you a Bolshevik it's just crazy
but as far as consuming this though yeah
is ESPN and Fox and whoever else this
man BC are they really still able to
monetize this yeah they are but at that
at some point advertisers can only pay
so much and then you couple in the other
part of that magic dual revenue stream
which is you know the the subscriber is
the sub fees and so they've lost you
know over 12 million in several years so
12 million subscribers so all the sudden
you know starts to add up to real money
I mean now you can convict or acquit
ESPN
now at this moment in their history
because should they have seen this
coming I mean when they were spending
all that money on 3d and a new digital
Center and all this other stuff I mean
should they have maybe been thinking
further down the road you know
absolutely but at the same time are they
in intensive care are they in real
serious trouble no it's just that we're
at a moment of dynamic change okay but
when what would constitute trouble Amber
Alert at the mothership well I mean look
it's trouble but it's not like you know
we're gonna they're gonna close the
place down I mean the biggest problem is
they are not delivering to Disney the
kind of multiple is the kind of money
that they used to I mean when you look
back on Disney's purchase of Pixar and
whatever I mean there's some there's
some ESPN money in there right ESPN was
unbelievable for Disney and for its
employees and now those kind of
multiples are nowhere to be found so
you're having to reengineer and they're
having to literally come up with a new
model and they're doing at a time of not
only losing cable subscribers but you
know
jonno ran great reporter reported
yesterday Facebook live was buying like
rice to the world surfing championship
yeah now it's it's just surfing I
understand but you know ESPN started
with you know football so you know it's
that's a sign of times and in three
years when the NFL deals start to come
up you have some people at Google and
there's some people elsewhere that you
know are gonna be coming to the plate so
like all the old rules are thrown out
the window right now but that's what I
want to know and I when I said I was
gonna have you on and people said is it
gonna be just 10 minutes of bashing ESPN
and I said no but I have to understand
what's going on at ESPN to understand
what it's going to mean for the consumer
five years ten years down the road
because this isn't just ESPN you
mentioned some other players that have
money Amazon Google Yahoo YouTube like
somebody's coming in and going to poach
something here when it when it comes up
for grabs do you see that
or do you see a la carte that's gonna
happen here with some of these other
companies you know ala carte used to be
the big thing that he has fee on when
you were at ESPN that was like
kryptonite right yes it was like oh my
gosh
and now it's just well the people aren't
I mean they're they're not even calling
the cable company they got Roku or Apple
TV or something like that so they're
losing subscribers in a serious way I
don't know I have a feeling you know
when like you go on iTunes and you want
to buy an album and we're song you pay a
dollar 99 for the song yeah um we could
be looking at a situation where you go
on your phone you go on your laptop or
whatever and you buy that that game so
you'll have an NBA pass for the entire
season or you you don't have some big
you know cable bill but you do
everything from your own customization
point of view so whatever you want and
it doesn't even mean that you have to
tie yourself into a particularly
you could just like just like you go on
iTunes and pick out a song you can pick
out okay I want to I want to watch the
words in the in the Cavs tonight and
I'll pay 399 for that game or 2 bucks or
whatever I mean I think that the one
thing that we know for sure is that this
is an incredibly dynamic moment in time
technology is now has been for a while
with ESPN wreaking havoc particularly on
SportsCenter but now it's disrupted the
very foundations of a model so now they
have to reexamine I could see a sports
vending machine where you just say I'd
like to press that button to get that
game and I get it for this amount of
money do I have to pay more for a
Cowboys game or a Patriots game
Cavaliers game or golden do you see that
where we have a two or three tiered
system where you're you're paying a
little more for something or is it gonna
be you know plan pricing in a way it
could be an extension of what we see
with StubHub which is like you go on if
you're gonna if you want to go to a game
and it's a hot game you're gonna be
paying more yeah so they could have
metrics where like if you're you know if
it's a matchup between top three teams
in each division for instance you know
then it's got this kind of multiple I
mean we see these things all over the
time I mean uber charges an upcharge
we're in prime you know prime traffic
time so there's no limit to that but I
think the days of just you know six six
dollars and fifty cents here cable bills
that that's go on
he's a Jim Miller wrote the book on ESPN
also Saturday Night Live joining us here
in the man cave if you gave the
network's a do-over let's say ten years
ago who do you who do you think would
have that you know I guess ESPN but what
does ESPN do ten years ago that gets
them in the right position now well look
Noah Noah built the ark before it
started raining right so I mean I think
they need to look ahead some of the
things I think three I'm gonna need a
second source on that with Noah though
he's gonna say Jim okay I mean look 3d
did not turn out to be the way they
wanted I think that the big digital
Center Sports Center got lost in that
Vorta I mean it was is this huge big
stage and these two little people and it
just that didn't seem to be right but I
also think you know you can go back and
you can look at some of the deals but
they the hard thing about ESPN is they
have 8760 hours to fill you know it's
it's an enormous beast and they had
across many different networks so it's
not like they can say to the NBA oh you
know what we don't want we don't want me
basketball this year for the next six
years
you know they can't say it to the NFL
for sure because you know they're
they're sub feet gets fundamentally
altered if they don't have the NFL so
they're at the mercy of these leagues I
mean I think that the hard part is
watching for them watching other
networks bid so much because in a way
look at Fox I mean they they spent a lot
of money on the Big Ten deal I mean
Turner spent a lot of money on on NBA so
where are they getting that their models
being disrupted to I mean at some point
you almost you always think that you
know you could eat the network's would
obviously be illegal but get together in
a room and say hey wait was fire we got
to get some control back because
otherwise they're the league's are doing
a great job at dividing and conquering
do we care about highlight shows anymore
Fox got rid of Dan and Jay who that's
the most talented team that you have do
and Fox couldn't find a home for him the
six o'clock SportsCenter Michael and
Jamel Scott Van Pelt has his own Sports
Center as well but highlights are
readily available whenever we want them
we don't have to wait for somebody to
edit them on our phones yeah so I mean
there's no barriers to entry and we can
just follow our own teams and
everything's so customized so I mean
look what they're doing with the six
o'clock SportsCenter is it's more about
the personalities than it is the
highlights and that's what happens with
Scott - you know you're basically tuning
name to see Scott Van Pelt like you
might with Jimmy Fallon Jimmy Kimmel or
or Steven so like you know they're I
think that's a smart move because
several years ago you had
indistinguishable no offense intended
but personalities doing those shows and
the only value proposition was to watch
the highlights well forget it
so I mean I think that they still have
they're not out of the woods with
SportsCenter but that is one of those
key areas where technology is just you
know it's been like a tsunami that
washed over what used to be yeah but my
knock was that you
you could get SportsCenter whenever you
wanted to whereas before you had
appointment viewing and you built teams
so you would tune in for the six o'clock
with Bob and Robin and Charley Steiner
and Keith and myself at 11:00 and you
know maybe the late one with Craig
killed like so you you had something
there appointment viewing but also you
look do you guys remember you used to
tease into the next segment and going
into commercial and when you come back
we'll tell you about the Giants in the
Padres game I mean it's like Giants and
the Padres game we are waiting to find
out the score whew yeah I mean there was
just no way so it's a just it's a it's a
totally different solar solar system I
mean it's like too crazy what technology
is doing
speaking of Saturday Night Live it feels
like Saturday Night Live reinvented
themselves again it is that I mean they
they became a lot more YouTube friendly
it feels like there's
these clips that you want to watch with
Saturday Night Live it is that fair
assessment of Saturday Night Live oh
yeah I mean look one of the keys to
being successful for 42 years is
adapting and when Alec Baldwin hosted
they were the number two show including
primetime and they did better that week
then the Big Bang Theory I mean that's
just that's just crazy and they got
really savvy digitally like back ones
along the oven guys were doing their
video shorts yeah
those that really created a port of
entry into the digital world so a lot of
people are watching the show without
watching the show
well Larry David comes in as you know
Bernie Sanders you got Alec Baldwin
doing this Donald Trump but it feels
like it's it's in their wheelhouse
because the Republicans have now taken
control politically and it gives them a
little bit more of an edge and more
juice there well I think that a godsend
for this is a great gift SNL and of
course Kate McKinnon is you know off the
charts crazy talented and I think one of
the things set is particularly
diabolical about what SNL is doing now
is they have the female cast playing
these male Trump administration people
which indicate yeah every time told
really ticks off people at the White
House oh we've been good that's probably
what they want right you know it's
probably a nice added bonus most
powerful people in sports media right
now you mean like suits are in front of
the camera in front of the camera and I
don't think anybody cares about the
suits behind I don't think anybody's
going boy you know John skipper
you know or Mark Lazarus but as far as
in front of the camera or just sports
media in general who would be number one
on your list well I mean it depends on
in terms of personality your properties
or whatever but I mean there's a fantasy
draft right now you can add anybody to
your network right now who is Jim Miller
you got first pick everybody's available
I don't know I mean look I I think there
was a real I think Bob Costas had an
amazing career I think that you know I
was glad to see he got the attention he
got when he turned over the baton for
the Olympics but he wouldn't be your
first pick - no he wouldn't he wouldn't
be my first choice you're building a
network you got to get eyeballs got to
make money yeah
I'm not sure I I kind of I have to say
are you free to skip bayless know who it
would be skipping Stephen a no I'm just
kidding but you know I think it I'm more
of a guy like it's I just feel like with
the property you know I mean it's all
about the property but we have debate
now debate has replaced highlights
debate is being embraced by everybody
now it feels like have you looked at
some of the numbers well I I'm saying if
I'm a viewer it feels like everything is
about debate is debate profitable is is
that sustainable well look first take at
ESPN and those guys got paid a lot of
money for a good reason
it was an amazing amount of tonnage
which you need yeah and it was
delivering young eyeballs
you know lots of lots of cold pizza in
front of those in front of those TVs and
you know is provocative and Steven a and
skip you know they were just they were
just saying whatever they want to
dissapoint at work because I think that
particularly with with young male
viewers they loved seeing these guys go
at it and the most outlandish opinions
even if they weren't supported by fact
you know were provocative maybe one day
that'll happen in politics oh wait Wow
no but you know I think that I think it
was enormous ly profitable and not only
that but that's the thing about that is
you can't get that on your phone you
can't look that up so you're talking
about proprietary yes material which is
why Jaime Horowitz had to pay what he
paid to get skip over or Colin over to
Fox because these are particular brands
and they have their followings
what sport would you buy stock in right
now I I mean I still believe in I think
the NBA somehow has weathered its storm
and even though the all-star game sucks
I think I think that even though the
rains may be little doubt I'd be worried
I'm worried about the NFL if I were an
NFL owner I'd actually I would actually
think about selling the next couple
years not only because of what's going
on in terms of the ratings but there's
own there's a more serious problem which
is I know 12 year old kid who's six feet
tall and he's a gorgeous athlete I mean
just a beautiful athlete can throw the
ball 40 yards in the air or the perfect
spiral and his parents aren't gonna let
him play high school football college
football yeah they're he's gonna be a
power forward or he's gonna be a pitcher
his parents like literally looked at me
and said that so you know 10 years ago
that guy's like a star quarterback in
college and then he's got the big in you
know NFL deal I worry about the supply
chain for the NFL yeah I think that what
is what has happened as far as the
concussion lawsuit the publicity the
movie that was out you're not feeling
that for about 10 years down the road
with the NFL
college football and the NFL UFC it sold
for four billion is that worth the
investment
yes doc so now they have to go and find
a TV rights to all that is going to
justify that and the question is you
know Fox is gonna want it but how many
other players can they get involved in
the bidding no otherwise I mean it said
that's it that's a tough price but you
know what
the good thing is that William Morris
Endeavor who bought it WME at least they
own it now they don't don't worry about
a client firing them their client they
own their client so there's a lot of
advantages to that how nervous would you
be with golf tennis it's all it's it's
it's all part of the larger picture
which is for some reason you know and
there's a lot you know people used to
say was Colin Kaepernick but no it's
happening over here it's happening in
here over here I I have a feeling that
all of these sports in their own ways
going to be reexamining their financial
models
we have a couple years until some big
negotiations come up NFL's gonna start
you know in cut just a couple years
because the deals start coming up in 20
and 21 that's gonna be mind-blowing I
think that that is going to be the
biggest vehicle to understanding where
all of sports broadcasting is going and
and you know TV rights and computer
rights and everything else is ESPN the
movies still gonna be made I hope so
script is done we actually have a star
attached and can you you know I'm at the
bottom of the food chain I can't I can't
can you give me a hint who like if it's
the star then who's playing me it's
Jason Bateman all right Jason Bateman
right yeah okay but the star attached is
playing what role can you tell me that
no Berman no he's are they gonna play
Berman no I think I play Olbermann I
can't
are they gonna play when I get summoned
all I'm trying to be a you know trying
to stay in my lane here can you tell me
writer is like you know can you tell me
the period of ESPN that will be the that
movie will be about what period I know
cuz they they they just want me to be
quiet so I want to be respectful I want
to get the bloody movie made am i part
of the movie is my character part of the
movie you know by the way there could be
there could be a rewrite next week and
all said okay but right you go from like
yeah okay if I'm in the original script
that's I'm fine with that
am I in this movie that's all I want to
know someone narcissistic you know yes
it is oh hello
that's a lot narcissistic okay just so
I'm in the movie my my my time at ESPN
was worth something
well thank you then I know how it ends
not pretty
tears like would you get past it I do
eventually there's a nice epilogue yeah
when I'm weeping when I walk out of ESPN
that day saying what did I just do it
shows you where to bank cashing a check
with a big last laugh I think yes that
laugh was something like this something
like that alright he's Jim Miller the
author of ESPN and Saturday Night Live
and also he has written the script for
ESPN the movie and he's not telling me
anything
that's great see Jim thank you for
stopping by the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience